معنا الان مشاهدينا من دبي مدرب اللياقه
البدنيه علاء رباط اهلا بك علاء كابتن
علاء معنا صباح الخير
كيفك صباح الخير معك علاء رباط انا مدرب
اللياقه البدنيه من دبي اليوم حابب احكي
لكم عن شويه نصائح بخصوص الرياضه
يا علاء
اول شيء طبعا في فصل الصيف خصوصا في
الخليج
هويات عاليه جدا فبالتالي كثير منا انا
بحاول اني ما اكون من هدول الناس ولكن
كثير منا بفضلوا
خلص مش ضروري بلاش اليوم
العب رياضه هل في اي طريقه بنقدر انه نخفف
من منطقه هذا الحر ومنخليه يمنعنا فيما
يتعلق يعني بنوعيه التمارين اللي بنعملها
او شرب ماء او غيره ما تخلي هذا الحر
يمنعنا من ممارسه الرياضه
هلا هو نحن المشكله
بالحر العالم كلها هي بترجع للصالات
الرياضيه او انه ممكن يزيد عندهم الكسل
انه انا ما بدي اتمرن لانه برا شوب فما
فيني انا اروح اتمرن في في تمارين منزليه
فيهم يعملوها بالبيت وفيهم يروحوا على
الصاله الرياضيه كمان طبعا هذا بغض النظر
انه لازم يتبعوا حميه غذائيه لازم يكون
عندهم كمان مدرب يشرف عليهم طيب خلينا
نشوف بعض التمارين على احنا حابين يعني
نعطي نصائح عمليه للمشاهدين
اكيد اكيد هلا نحن حاليا لما بدنا نتمرن
لازم اول شيء نحن نبلش بتمارين الاحماء
لحتى نتفادى اي اصابات او اي مشاكل ممكن
تعارضنا بخلال التمرين تمام فهو اهم شيء
نحن انه نبلش بتمارين الاحماء لحتى نهيئ
الجسم قبل ما انه نفوت ونتمرن فيه بشكل
كامل وما يكون مهيا وهون الاصابات اللي هي
بتبلش فاهم شي انه تعملوا احنا لكامل
الجسم حتى الاجرين في كثير عالم بتتفادى
الاجرين انه يعملوا التمارين الاجرين او
انه بدهم يبلشوا فورا هو بتمارين
الجسم من فوق بس اهم شيء انه يبلشوا
بتمارين الاحماء وبعدين فيهم يبلشوا
بالتمارين هلا كمان لازم قبل قبل اي
تمارين هن يبلشوا فيها يبلشوا بجهاز المشي
ليش جهاز المشي لانه هو بساعد عضله القلب
على انه تستوعب
كميه اكبر من الدم يمشي الدم اكثر
بالشرايين
تزبط معدل الاكسجين عندهم هاي اهم شيء
بتلاقيهم فورا
التجهوا للتمارين بدون الاحماء بدون جهاز
المشي المبدا من جهاز المشي هو مش انه
بنزل الوزن هو بساعد على افراز الهرمونات
اكثر على
تعديل نبضات القلب تهيئ الجسم
هلا هي الهروله هي المبدا منها على انه
تطلع كامل المي من الجسم انت لما بتعرق
بخلال الهروله تمام هو انت عم تطلع المي
المخزنه عندك بالجسم المي بتتخزن بجسم كيف
عن طريق الاكل طيب في احيانا الاكل هو ما
بيقدر يهضم كامل علاء خلصنا التسخين شنو
التمرين هل اتمرن مثل الايام العاديه اذا
في حال اذا كنت اتمرن هل اتمرن في مثل
الايام العاديه ولا انه لا بالصيف له
تمارين خاصه اخف وزن الى اخره
هلا هو بالصيف
اللي يفضل انه ما تزيد كتير من شده
التمرين لانه هو الرد بيكون برا الجو شوب
الجسم مانو مهيا كتير انه يتمرن اهم شيء
انه تحافظ على المستوى المي بالجسم بتشرب
مي بخلال التمرين تمام تكون اكل قبل قبل
التمرين ما بمد انه تكون كتير قريبه من
التمرين بس لحتى يهيقك ويكون انه جسمك
جاهز فيه الفيتامينات والبروتينات اللي
نحن بنحتاجها بخلال التمرين لحتى تعطينا
الطاقه
كانه ما بين التمرين والتمرين من الضروري
شرب الماء مثلا لانه الواحد يتعرق اكثر
بفصل الصيف وبالحراره فعشان او مثلا ياخذ
اي شيء يعيد الاملاح ايضا مثلا يشرب شيء
خلال التمرين يعيد الاملاح لجسمه
طبعا هو المي هي لازم تكون الشيء الرئيسي
هو الموجود في خلال التمرين كتير عالم ما
بتشرب مي بالتمرين انا دائما بنصح وبقول
انه هو لازم تشرب مي لانه اذا ما بتشرب مي
معدل الاكسجين عندك بيكون كتير نازل
فبتلاقيهم احيانا بحسوا بالنعاس احيانا
انه ما عندهم الطاقه انه يتمرنوا فلهيك من
الافضل انه نحافظ على مستوى شرب الماء
بخلال التمرين ويفضل ان تشرب بس خليني
اقاطعك لانه باقي عندنا دقيقه ونص وانا
حابب اني استفاد من عندك باي التمارين من
الممكن ان ناخذها في وسط الصيف نكررها
اكثر
سريعا دقيقه ونص تمام هلا هو اهم شيء تمام
اهم شيء انه نبلش في جهاز المشي لحتى نحمي
الجسم تمام وبعدين بنلجا للتمارين اللي هي
شبه هوائيه او انه باستعمال الدامبلز طبعا
الوزن لازم اكون جسمك فيه يتحمله ما لازم
تضغط حالك اكثر من هيك تمام اهم شيء انه
نحافظ على التمارين اللي
بتبين لنا التفاصيل الجسم اكثر او اللي
ممكن تساعدنا على الحركه اكثر اللي هي
عندك مثلا مثل التمرين البايسبس لتقويه
الزراعه الايدين عندك تمارين اللي بتساعد
لتقويه الشولدر والظهر تمام وعندك كمان
فيل تمارين اللي فيك بتكون متسطح فيها على
البنش هي لحتى تقوي عندك عضله الصدر
والظهر بنفس الوقت
تمام
وبعد عن هيك اللي هي التمارين المعده اللي
هو اهم شيء لازم نلعبها نحن وفي كتير عالم
بتدفعناها لهيك بعدين بيطلع لهم
تعلمي عادل تعلم عندك التمارين المعده هي
اللي بتحافظ على منطقه الكور وبتقوي عندك
كمان عضله الظهر من تحت
طيب عندك هيك وعندك كمان اللي بتساعد
بتحريك الاجرين بنفس الوقت لحتى
على
التمارين اللي يعني بنمارسها ببقيه اوقات
السنه ولكن لازم نكون حريصين بانه ما نثقل
او نحط جسمنا تحت ضغط اضافي في فصل الصيف
اشكرك جزيل الشكر
التمرين وخلال التمرين بعد التمرين تروحون
تاكلون ايس كريمة
شكرا يا علاء يعطيك العافيه نشوفك المره
الجايه
لمتابعتي المزيد من الاخبار والبرامج
والقصص الانسانيه والوثائقيات والتقارير
الاخباريه لا تنسوا الاشتراك في قناتنا
على اليوتيوب الضغط على زر الاعجاب وتفعيل
جرس التنبيهات